the ability to take off and zip along in
a flying car is no longer a fantasy
companies from startups to aerospace
heavyweights are competing to develop
and make them commercially viable
designed to elevate us free us from
highways on the ground to skyways in the
air
flying cars could change how we commute
work and live
the designs vary but the cars may look
more like futuristic helicopters or
oversized drones
some will fly without a pilot others are
designed to be air taxis
at the forefront of all of this is
marcus lang a canadian engineer and
inventor in the rolling hills and open
skies of warkworth ontario he came up
with a novel way to drive
i think we've all had dreams of
complete three-dimensional freedom i
remember as a young boy walking to to
school and sort of
you know wondering if it would ever be
an aircraft where you could just jump in
and be able to take off vertically and
fly wherever you want to it was in the
summer of 2009 when lang was working on
a different aviation project that he
began to realize his dream could become
reality i did some calculations
with the current technology and realized
at that point
that electric vtol was not only possible
but was practical
and
that was the eureka moment
so this is where it all happened of
course this is nothing like what this
place was like
when it was a full shop but
i still have a few pieces left
he went to work in his basement and he
was able to build the first prototypes
of what is now known as blackfly
a new form of vehicle that doesn't need
a runway to fly it's an electric vtol or
eevee tall which is short for electric
vertical takeoff and landing i think our
house became a factory
the basement was used for basically
doing all the structures work the
kitchen were basically used for
manufacturing motors we used to bake the
motors in the
in the oven
boy would that stink
in october 2011 the moment of truth lang
flew his first proof of concept in his
front yard i found myself the at the end
of our driveway
my friends and neighbors were
behind a barrier of cars that we had set
up and i figured just like in skiing
i'll do a skidding turn in front of them
the
edge of the wing contacted the lawn and
i still recall sort of going this isn't
going to end well but
the propulsion systems reacted so fast
that after landing at that point i
realized how incredible this technology
was a few years later lang moved the
majority of his operations to silicon
valley in northern california a hub of
tech innovations and startups it was
here his company opener clandestinely
set to work on perfecting blackfly it is
a personal aerial vehicle it's not
designed for multiple people it's
designed for one individual to give them
the freedom to basically go where they
want to go the nice thing about our
vehicle is both the united states and
canada is classified as an ultralight
aircraft in canada you require an
ultralight license which is
relatively easy and straightforward too
to obtain
i think the most unique thing is that i
can be
an operator you can be an operator
anyone who is over the age of 18 which
is our kind of limit is able to learn in
the course of
two days and a few hours of simulation
how to safely fly this aircraft so that
is something that is exceptionally novel
and really incredible to be able to give
that type of experience to regular
people what rpm are the promoters
running at right now christina menton is
the director of operations flight
testing and propulsion lead at opener so
the aircraft is almost exclusively made
from carbon fiber the wings and the
fuselage are made from carbon fiber
the propellers are carbon fiber we have
electric motors that we build ourselves
in house and have designed in-house and
these are the most power dense electric
motors in the world for their size
they're about four and a half pounds and
just over 25 horsepower menton says one
of the unique features of this
all-electric vehicle is it's amphibious
meaning it can take off and land on
water
and it has a return to home button we
have auto land features
so basically when you get close to the
ground the aircraft will take over and
the aircraft will land you so that you
can land whether you press return to
home it'll land you right back on the
spot that you want to be
or you bring it down to a new location
blackfly is controlled by a joystick can
fly in 20 mile per hour winds and
operate in extremely cold weather
anyone up to six feet six inches tall
weighing 200 pounds or less can use it
in the united states which is our
primary market we have
very serious weight restrictions
so the american
vehicles have a 20 plus mile range for
an operator that's 200 pounds in the
united states we're restricted
62 miles an hour in canada we don't have
those weight constraints and also we
don't have speed constraints according
to lang all testing is done autonomously
and black fly has flown more than 35 000
miles in test flights
it's unbelievable
i could not have conceived
where we are today from where we were 10
years ago developing blackfly doesn't
just happen
in one swift moment it's an evolutionary
process and to date we have built and
flown 40 aircraft every single aircraft
has been an improvement on the
predecessor
the ev tall field is hyper competitive
so lane needed to find ingenious
creative minds to help fulfill his dream
and he found them in canada
menton and her classmate eleanor lee who
is now the plant manager had just
finished their mechanical engineering
degrees at the university of toronto
when they got the call from lang both
signed on and moved to the u.s
before they even knew exactly what
project they'd be working on marcus
basically came along and said oh we're
making this huge carbon epoxy part do
you want to be part of our team and i
just said yes
yes here i am
i first met marcus on a phone call the
day before my last exam of university at
the time the company was completely in
stealth mode and he wasn't able to say
what the product was who the investors
were or really any of the technical
details
but i could get from the phone call that
it was a pretty exciting and innovative
opportunity and decided to take the leap
to jump on board
for years lang worked in the shadows
keeping his invention secret while
recruiting it was only in 2018 that he
began to lift the veil letting the
public get a glimpse of blackfly and how
it works he gave us a tour this is our
testing lab and what you see before you
hear are different propulsion systems
that run 24 7 and then finally we have
what we call the punch test and it
basically is going to operate uh it's
going to go from standstill to about 80
percent uh max thrust in about 1.2
seconds this testing is all about making
sure that you've got very robust systems
[Music]
that was some thrust for sure
it works i guess
it works
it's been a long process but it seems
that hard work is paying off from the
first day we went flight testing
you know a few things didn't work and we
were only trying to fly 10 miles
and over the years as a team we've flown
five miles 10 miles 30 miles and at 10
000 20 000 40 000 miles and we flew in
front of 60 000 people like that's
incredible
so all of that
has been my personal success and also
the success of the company and i'm
really proud to be part of this
[Music]
here she goes
in july 2021 at a rare public appearance
lee menton and lang flew blackfly at a
popular aircraft show in oshkosh
wisconsin the annual event can draw
hundreds of thousands of spectators
the flight is incredible like you have
panoramic view of
anywhere that you fly at
[Music]
it's an experience
i told this to a few people at oshkosh
when you're in the aircraft you feel
like you are the aircraft and the
aircraft is you
[Music]
that just keeps getting better and
better
still awesome
christina showed me how to do that
the company hopes to start selling
blackfly soon lang says for now it can
only fly in rural areas and not over
cities safety is the number one priority
the
whole idea with the aircraft is that it
has to be
safe for someone without a pilot's
license to be able to fly we have to
have a triple modular redundant system
so triple modular redundant means that
there's three systems so if one system
fails there's still two systems that are
functioning and then you know which one
has failed and which one you should be
flying off of it does also have a
parachute and we consider that the very
last line of defense the first versions
will likely be expensive lang is keeping
the price tag under wraps but he
believes as the industry advances it
will become accessible to more people he
told us the ultimate goal is to produce
tens of thousands of these vehicles at a
price that would be similar to the cost
of an suv and if that becomes true
it will make his childhood dream take
flight i start to project because i want
one
they're going to be going on sale in the
very near future
and
i'm going to get the first one off the
line
you